now thankful for me all of these are
edges are the same so I could work out
whichever one I like so I'm just going
to pick one that's convenient for me i'm
going to choose my point of view coming
from this angle ok so i'm going to try
and work out what a B is i'll try to try
and draw a diagram that will show me
what a B is and then I can work out the
side way I can work out the area of this
square from there so if I'm standing
over there right if you like I'm
standing behind this part of the planets
it's still the same diagram right it's
still oriented the same way ok I'm
looking at it side on so what kind of
shape do I observe and another quadrant
right what I'm doing is I'm looking
right down through this quarter pipe ok
so therefore i'm going to draw from my
orientation this is what i see here's my
quarter circle now where is a be the
current IB that I've drawn on my diagram
well it's kind of I've got a half way up
so I have it a be like this I told them
I've done that words that a that's be ok
and this is the length I'm trying to
work out I also know that this quiet
above the base right that's I'm just
calling that age so to work out a bee I
just need one more piece of information
what should I add on you Thanks so I
actually load this base right I actually
will say that i'll go ahead and say it
because you can see that base comes from
this is the edge i'm looking at here
right which is a but hold on this is not
just any shape right this is a quadrant
yeah it's a quadrat so therefore the
radius everywhere is also a right so i'm
going to put this in here which is a as
well ok but because I've chosen to have
flat slices like that i'm just going to
write a betrayal that's really nice ok
so I'm going to say off of this right
maybe squared
by the way a B squared plus h squared
equals a squared you okay that that's
Pythagoras there in triangle OAB what am
I trying to find out yeah I'm going off
top I want a B because that's the side
length of this square which will give me
the area from which i can calculate the
volume okay so therefore I'm going to
make a be the subject now ordinarily at
this step I would take the square root
of both sides so they'll have a V equals
whatever but in this case I'm not going
to do that why not quite we're not
working honey bee again because of the
area of a square well the area of a
square is a side length swear so I
already have it it's done I don't need
to take the square root and then square
that again that's just extra work okay
so that that is area of cross section
please note a is that constant is
whatever the various office quarter pipe
beers but H is variable H is variable
and that's why you can see my Delta H
here I'm going to integrate with respect
to H shortly okay I'm ready the volume
is equal to all right what is changing
what's shrinking dr. H as a consequence
because I'm thinking about a cheese
right I'm going to integrate from I'm
going to sum up the swears from H equals
what to what yeah very good one over H
equals 0 that will give you the largest
basis right so the area of that square
look at it when H equals zero the area
of that bottom square is a square look
there it is right there I already know
what it is and of course when so there's
what I'm starting when h is equal to
right at the top in be a what's the area
of that square it'll be a squared minus
a squared which is zero it's that point
perfect in here I'm just going to be
adding up all of these squares right but
of course I need a thickness cuz I the
volume which in this case is the page
okay really let's evaluate this thing
this is 0 2 a of a squared minus H
squared D H remember remember is
constant so what does a square integrate
into x square H it's just a constant H
squared and turns into and then you're
going from Malta a so what are we going
to end up with a cubed a third a cubed +
0 so that looks to be lucky two thirds
I'm a cute okay so let me reiterate and
you'll start to get a sense of this
right the actual integration even the
geometry is not complicated right it's
just seeing your way through the diagram
and having to be patiently you know
drawing diagram and then not the diagram
and then now that I am 20 hours 41 like
I said depending on where this question
appears in the paper they would kind of
hold your hand more or less in this
particular question at India to see they
actually even gave you this diagram so
it's kind of like a lot of the mental
work has been done for you however I
think it's dangerous to fall into the
trap of thinking oh great they've
already given this to me drawing the
diagram constructor you helped us to
understand and make sure we knew what
was going on so there's an easy trap to
fall into and that you can chalk this
incorrectly because we didn't construct
this one right so even they give your
diagram I kind of size it off draw your
own what it's very very helpful ok